as u.s troops arrived in poland and
russia flexed its most sophisticated
missile systems around the gulf of
finland the leaders of france and russia
sought to settle their differences over
the gravest threat to european security
in decades
socially distanced geopolitically pulls
apart
there are some areas of convergence
between russia and france you yourself
have started talks with nato in america
and in the next few weeks we'll be able
to have concrete discussions to build on
these discussions for peace and security
the french president came to the kremlin
after consultations with allies and left
without the historic solution that he
was after
if each nato member state has its own
role to play in what they hope is a
complementary and united response to
possible kremlin aggression then it's
fair to say that france sits on the
softer end of that spectrum emmanuel
macron has tried really since the start
of his presidency to court russia and so
far it hasn't paid off
in washington germany's new chancellor
olaf schultz paid his first visit to the
white house a warmer affair than the
scene in moscow and a chance for the u.s
president to dispel any concerns over
german resolve
german and united states are close
friends
and reliable partners and we can count
on one another
there is no issue of global importance
where germany and the united states are
not working together
strength
as its military gets ready for huge
joint drills in belarus within striking
distance of the ukrainian capital russia
still insists that this isn't about war
or ukraine
ukraine speaking to sky news the prime
minister of lithuania said it was about
far more
i think that
it's better be ready than sorry there is
a very significant change in uh
official
approach how kremlin sees the
world and
we would
we can call this uh
an attempt to
recreate something like soviet union 2.0
and so the ukrainians ready themselves
as the diplomacy continues in the search
for historic solutions which makaha
hoped he'd get still some way off